[Applause]
hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my Batman Catwoman wedding reaction
video if you guys didn't know this is
the 16th time that Batman has been
married or tried to get married in the
comics so obviously spoiler warning if
you have not read the story yet there
was a big story going around last week
because the New York Times supposedly
spoiled the ending of the story but the
current writer on Batman Tom King the
person who's the architect of all this
said that issue 50 which is the wedding
issue is only the halfway point in a
Batman Catwoman arc that's going to last
400 issues so he compared this issue to
the moment in Empire Strikes Back where
Han Solo's gun gets ripped out of his
hand by Darth Vader we would be honored
if you would join us hopefully that
doesn't mean that Batman's gonna get
frozen by mr. freeze and a couple more
issues and then sold to the penguin and
put up as a decoration in the iceberg
lounge but if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's gonna be a bunch more
DC happening really soon because it's a
wedding issue I will do a new round of
that flash ring giveaway - all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video the
Ruby conversation the last couple of
days was on the ending of the issue
where you know obviously we're in
spoiler territory now so just careful
for spoilers one more time
Catwoman decides that Batman needs his
misery if she tries to make him happy
she's worried that it will break him he
won't be Batman anymore and he won't be
able to bring hope to people the way he
has in the past so she bails on the
wedding and this is issue 50 remember
hundred issue Ark but then the teaser at
the end is that we find that Bane has
been the architect of this entire 50
issue run where he slowly realizes that
he loves Catwoman proposes do they try
to get married he engineered that plan
to fail so that he could you know
quote-unquote break the bat so he's
sitting up on his perch there you see
Holly Robinson kneel down to him like
she's been doing this in service of him
like she was the one that planted the
idea and Catwoman
I always kind of felt like Batman needed
his misery then a little light bulb goes
on above Selina Kyle's head like oh wait
a minute
maybe Batman doesn't eat his misery then
you see all the other people standing
around there you have the Joker
you have the Riddler and it looks like
even though they had this big lead up
with all the different characters
interacting with Batman like you had
this whole big arc about villains being
upset about how Batman was going to
change because of this wedding even just
a little while ago the Joker was
threatening to crash the wedding he was
really upset because he felt like his
relationship with Batman took president
and he felt like he needed Batman to be
Batman I could destroy the entire city
and I need Batman to stop me it was
probably one of the best Joker issues
that I've ever read but now you find out
that it almost seems like he was doing
this in service of whatever Bane's plan
was probably the biggest Easter egg is
you look over here and you see what
looks like Thomas Wayne in his Batman
costume standing in Bane's line up and
you're like wait a minute didn't we
watch him die during the button
crossover like there was this whole
backstory with him getting to meet his
father the flashpoint father where he
says don't be Batman anymore go be happy
he told him to stop being Batman now it
seems like that was all part of Bane's
plan which just blows your mind because
that was actually a really big crossover
issue with the flash so it seems like
Bane has just gotten the bright idea
that he can break the Batman more
effectively if he does it emotionally
like breaking his body isn't enough
because Batman will always keep coming
back but you give him a deep emotional
scar that might wound him even more but
I think the idea is that we don't know
how Batman's going to react to this so
it was like well back to the grind and
then that's the last you hear of him
because the rest of the issue is them
revealing this big Bane twist I think a
good example of this is in Batman
Returns with the way they leave the
Catwoman Batman relationship like they
imply that he knows she's out there
somewhere they still care about each
other you have to imagine that a version
of this relationship that tonk king is
playing out is playing out in this
universe too
[Music]
I would love to live with you in your
castle just to address the New York
Times spoiler from a couple days ago I
wasn't quite as upset about it is a lot
of people I think mostly because it
confirmed what I felt about the Batman
character like it would be a little
weird if they tried to do the exact same
thing they did with Superman Lois Lane
and Jon Kent were there like this happy
little family like they do have a family
but it's an unconventional family and I
think that's one of the reasons why it
works Batman does kind of need his
misery but he can at the same time also
be happy so I think you know early
prediction for the end of this hundred
issue arc is that he and Catwoman
do wind up together they don't get
married in the conventional sense but
they do remain a couple and the way they
have been in the past like they've
always had chemistry they've always been
destined to be together but not
necessarily in the conventional Superman
or even Barry Allen iris West kind of
way so issue hundred if that's going to
be the end of this Tom King run they
wind up together but maybe there's a
little bit of i winking in an ambiguous
type of wedding moment where you could
say that kind of they're married but not
really there's always this weird line
that you walk with Batman like it always
did feel like it was kind of off limits
to get him married despite the fact that
he's been married 15 times before in the
comics the thing is though is that most
of those never stuck or they were taking
place in alternate universes so like you
have him getting married to earth to
Catwoman or they did this else world
story where you see an alternate version
of Batman and Catwoman grow old together
they sort of find ways to give you that
story without necessarily trampling on
main continuity like this is the regular
version of Batman he needs his misery he
can't get married but he can totally get
it on with Catwoman until the end of
time and they can't be together just not
in the way that you would think you know
other superheroes getting married the
conventional way would I think a lot of
that just goes into the DC characters
perspective origins in their most
popular arcs those mostly define the way
you think about what a character would
do what a character would not do like
throughout the history of DC Comics
Barry Allen has always
had a pretty solid marriage to iris west
there has been a whole lot of drama
between the two of them even though he
died during Infinite Crisis so iris
became world like this old woman advisor
but they had children in the future
called the tornado twins so you do have
a lot of conventional superhero
relationships where they get married
they have children they eventually die
the children take over but I think part
of the appeal of the Batman character is
in how untraditional he is and how he
makes his really hodgepodge family work
like you have Damian the circumstances
of his existence are also really twisty
his relationship with Talia al Ghul I
was also a fan of the way Tom King wrote
Talia during this arc when she found out
that Batman had gotten engaged so
remember now that you had the issue
where they sort of break things off the
rest of the bat family can react to it
like you can find out how Batman deals
with it like how was Nightwing going to
deal with Batman being left at the altar
how is Damian going to deal with it the
funniest thing from the issue there like
it's not all seriousness is watching
Alfred almost ready to cry at every
moment like this whole time he's so
happy because he's raised Bruce by
himself so he's kind of like his
surrogate father he tells him it's
always been us Alfred I couldn't do
anything without you and he just kind of
breaks down but let me know in the
comments what do you think about this
whole Batman Catwoman wedding and do you
believe that Batman needs his misery in
order to bring people hope but what's
gonna happen is is I learned a whole
bunch about Titans there was a recent
interview that one of the characters did
so I'll do a video for that soon I'll
announce a new winner when I post a new
DC there might be some new Rick and
Morty tonight too so just look out for
that but click here to learn all about
titans episode 1 and click here to learn
about all the deleted scenes that are
gonna be on the infinity war blu-ray
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight